- Hello Believe Nation.
I'm Evan Carmichael,
my one word is believe.
And I believe that entrepreneurs
are going to solve all of the major
problems of the world.
So to help you on your journey,
today we're going to learn from Chinese
actor Jet Li and my take on his
top 10 rules for success.
Rule number two is my personal favorite.
And I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And, as always, guys as you're watching
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it down
in the comments below.
Put quotes around it, so
other people can be inspired.
And when you write it
down, it's much more likely
to stick, for yourself as well, enjoy.
(upbeat music)
(speaks in foreign language)
- Well always in my life, believed
the biggest enemy is ourself.
We need to fight.
You know, learning special
professional martial arts,
everybody get a lot of
injuries in the past.
You need to fight with them.
- Overcome.
- Every day, you need to
work, continue to show--
- [Man] Strength
- strength,
and do your best.
So I think the real meaning to Fearless,
today from Jet Li's head,
is do your best every day.
- That's your knowledge.
- That's it, and the
lih-ter is going to come.
You cannot control, let them go.
Let them come, it doesn't matter.
Do your best at everything, everyday.
Everyday training, work,
everything's good enough.
If I do something, I do my best.
I don't know the future but if I really
want to do, I start, I do my best.
I'm not Bruce Lee.
I never can be Bruce Lee.
He is a different age,
a different philosophy maybe.
A lot of things are different.
Every human being is unique.
You have your special ability.
You need to make that become unique.
If you follow someone, then
always you're the follower.
You are not a creator.
I always tell myself, forgot the past.
What I did on the past.
I'm a new guy today.
And every day is new things happen.
I need to learn English.
I need to learn things,
learn American style.
This movie is a success, but
then the next movie maybe not.
So you need to learn again.
I'm a new actor every day.
So this is my philosophy, I need to learn.
I just normal guy, I play
the different characters.
Also, I need to learn every day.
Chinese have world famous
descendants, how to translate?
When you become older, older,
you still need to learn, how
to translate that sentence?
(speaks in foreign language)
- [Man] That's about right.
- Yeah, you become older, older, older.
But you still need to study, study, study.
Because that's a very good sentence there.
You need to prove to the world,
what you can do better than the other.
So that means you need to find yourself,
physically and mentally.
You always need to prove yourself
even if you do something different.
and if you can show your talent,
and you prove, of course,
you have a very good future.
I really hope all the Asians or all
the Canadians in the world, they need
to create their own.
Even you can learn something special
from different people.
But you need to make it yourself.
Prove yourself, you're the one.
In China, harder than the States
because in States, people just like it.
Then they either have a job,
they have a family, they
need to go to school,
and they training, two hours,
maybe three times a week.
But in China, lot of students training
eight hours a day.
Still training eight hours a day.
So this is why they work so hard.
(man speaks in foreign language)
- I remember once we need to put
my legs on the wall, just
like that, for four hours.
(laughs)
Four hours, and then the teacher is gone.
We don't know, where is the teacher?
But we're scared the teacher,
anytime, maybe he come back.
So we still keep the leg on the wall.
For four hours, after four hours,
that's the whole training.
Nothing, just one leg, put on the wall.
After that, we walking like a dog,
just couldn't walk.
I think whether you're a success or not,
you just become happier to do,
what you really want to do.
Not for just the name or money.
You need to do something
you really want to do.
That feeling is the most important for me.
Every day, every moment,
I still think about
how to helping people in the world.
For myself, I want to promote
how to help people, it's more important.
It's like, if I do make
a martial arts movie,
maybe not so many people
know martial arts.
What is martial arts?
What is Kung Fu in China?
So I'm not an independent
open school to teaching,
but I'm a promoter of martial arts.
Just like right now, I promote new ways
to do NGO and philanthropy
in the 21st Century.
Everybody can do it.
When we talk about helping people,
many, many ways you can do it.
- [Narrator] The philosophy
behind the foundation
is that a small donation, made regularly
by many people, can make a huge difference
to the lives of millions in need.
Or as Jet puts it, "If one person
"donates $1.00 every one month,
"that adds up to one big happy family."
- The humans will live in Earth,
like a big, global family.
So one foundation, one family.
Every human being, even we are
religion different, system different,
the language is different,
the color different,
but we're human.
We need helping each other, not just
Chinese people helping Chinese.
We need everybody helping each other.
- Jet Li is a very private man.
I think he's hiding something.
- He's all right, he's been
around a long, long time.
- Always say, he's so religious.
The truth is, he love party.
He go home, drinking, smoking,
but every morning he feel guilty.
- Jet Li always talk about
his best movie, Rush Hour.
Work with superstar, Chris Tucker.
But I met Chris Tucker,
he say he really want to
work with me, not Jackie.
- Jet always compare
himself to Chris Tucker.
"You know, Chris Tucker is
very big man," he knows.
- Jet Li really likes
collecting cars, watches.
You know, the reason, is
because he's really, small.
- And he demands everybody
call him on the set, hero.
Hero that, hero that.
"Would you like a cup of tea, hero?
"Would you like some foot massage, hero?"
Oh yeah, another thing, on the set,
you cannot look him in the eyes.
He'll fire you, ridiculous.
- And Jackie he always make jokes,
you know, everybody make everybody laugh.
But you know, not everybody laugh.
If you don't laugh, he fire you.
- You know, Jet always shave his hair
to prove he's very tough.
The truth is, his hair
very dry, sticking out.
He need to shave.
- You know why I work on the side?
He always show his muscle.
Change the pants to show
he's a powerful man.
But I'm starting to worry about his hair.
He start losing hair.
- I offer him Jackie Chan
product for his hair.
He refuse to use.
- Without hair, he's nothing.
(speaks in foreign language)
(audience laughs)
(instrumental music)
- Thank you guys, so much, for watching.
I made this video because
Amanda McBride asked me to.
So if there's someone
you'd like me to cover
in the next top 10
video, check out the link
in the description so you
can go and cast your vote.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Bo Hawkins.
Bo, thank you so much for picking
up a copy of my book, Your One Word,
and doing that interview on
your new YouTube Channel.
It was an awesome time and
I appreciate the support.
- Today I'm joined by the
outstanding, Evan Carmichael.
So if you've been online and you don't
know who he is, you've probably lived
under a rock for the past, infinite time.
- So thank you guys, again, for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
- For the big picture, you can know
human beings have a 5,000 history, right?
Everything had to protect peoples.
A lot of things happened.
Why we're how hard we try.
Next 5,000 years still
have a lot of problem.
Cannot be perfect, perfect, perfect.
It's not this planet, not this Earth.
Because we have a lot of cultures,
a lot of religions, a lot of things,
lot of disaster, lot of problems.
Today we face this
problem, 200 years later
they face another problem.
The most important we want to share
is 21st Century beliefs.
If every human being do a little bit,
not just earthquakes, a lot of things.
Education, you know, a lot
of things we can change.
I think belief is the most important.
That's why the Harvard professor tell me,
he say, "I like your idea.
"I want to study your idea, you know,
"become a class.
"Because everybody come to my office,
"ask, how to get the money.
"'I need the money, teach
me how to get the money.'
"So everybody talk about
money, money, money, money."
But One Foundation is the
first one is not the money,
it's the heart.
If you can share the beliefs
to the people's heart,
he will, he come in.
More people join the family.
A thick, very strong foundation.
Because think about it, in China, in China
we have a 72 people.
Even if we have 200 people, how to solve
a billion people's
problems, it's impossible.
But if everybody joins this family,
we can do something.
- For you it sounds like it's
about selling the belief?
In the world of six billion people.
If you can get each one, every one,
to do something, the impact will be huge.
- That's why, in the so
far, we did a lot of things.
A lot of them is because Jet Li's famous?
No, it's a lot of NGOs
helping us, 70 NGOs.
A lot of companies,
they don't need a name.
They just support the One Foundation.
As the whole foundation moving together
we go to Sichuan, we have 500 volunteers.
Where did it come from?
I don't know, I don't
even know their name.
They work very hard, harder than Jet Li.
Jet Li do what?
Jet Li is just planning.
They really do something.
Go through the mail, lot of places.
It's great things they do.
I really want to say, the family.
It's not Jet Li, it's not even foundation.
The family power is very strong.
(audience applauds)
Now remember, two years ago,
when the Joel Silver offered me to play
the bad guy, villain in Lethal Weapon 4.
Then I say, "Oh, I made 25 movies
"in Hong Kong, I never played the villain.
"So I don't know if my audience,
"what's their reaction
when they heard the news."
So he said, "Don't worry,
here is the good guy."
He offered another movie, Romeo Must Die.
So one bad guy, one good guy.
You can work, you have special skill.
You can make money for the studio.
Then in the future, right now,
maybe better than
before, have a little bit
of a chance, can choose what kind of story
I really want to make.
I hope in the future I have more chance
to choose what kind of
story I really want to make.
What kind of story I don't want to make.
- Hi Jet Li, my name is
Twi and I'm from Australia.
You say you are very
successful and that's obvious.
And smiling and optimistic,
and that's fabulous.
But I believe every successful person
has failures or experienced
set backs in their life.
Can you share with us what are some
of your failures in life?
And how you overcome this,
to achieve success in
your life, thank you.
(speaks in foreign language)
- "When it comes to setbacks and successes
"I think they're just normal to me.
"I would like to look at
it with a peaceful mind.
"It's just like for your hand.
"You have palm and you
have back of your palm.
"So these are two things just being there.
"If you talk about successful people
"you can think about the Chinese emperors
"in the past few hundred years.
"Are they successful?
"I don't even remember some of the names
"of these emperors.
"So when it comes to success, it really
"depends on definition of success.
"And in different times, people
defined success differently.
"And for me, it's like,
success to me is like,
"every day I have to live it meaningfully.
"I don't want to do something bad.
"And when I die I should be able
"to face my ancestors,
my teachers, my parents.
"So I don't really know when I'll die.
"So that's the reason I have to make use
"of every day, when I'm leaving here,
"to do something.
"I can't say I will wait until I retire
"to do something for philanthropy.
"No, it's not that.
"And good things, bad
things, they're just normal.
"They're just common things to me,
"like stocks if they go up, last year,
"it's normal to me.
"Last year, it goes down, it goes down.
"And this year it goes up,
it's all normal to me."